de la valse à l'habitude fait la
réputation de la petite ville au nord de
montréal mais ces puces
on la qualifie encore parfois de villes
dortoirs la troisième ville en
importance au québec
[Musique]
pas encore je m'impose que se présentent
tous vécu pas bp doter les élections
municipales semblent pourtant suscité
peu d'intérêt malgré les huit candidats
qui se présentent à la mairie les genres
en très forte majorité me disent ça vaut
bien satisfaire les finances publiques
sont en ordre la croissance est au
rendez vous et c'est sur ce bilan que le
candidat du mouvement lavallois fait
campagne on ne crée des belles fondation
maintenant il faut construire le reste
de la maison et donc c'est de ne pas
perdre ce bel élan l'ofs la coupure avec
la corruption de l'air vaillancourt est
aussi effectuer le dauphin du maire
sortant marc demers mise d'ailleurs
aussi sur ce legs le fait de ne plus
être des journaux pour de mauvaises
raisons
de la façon systématique comme il les
tient laval n'a jamais eu autant de
subventions des autres paliers de
gouvernement 80
mais la vision du candidat michel
trottier est tout autre comme ici rien
créé al arab depuis huit ans je pose sur
tr mois qu'on parle pas de laval un
leadership fort de meilleurs services de
proximité il y a beaucoup à faire selon
lui ça aboutit pas actuellement les
grands projets à la vague bio
méthanisation complexe aquatique sentent
animalistes haute des projections tombé
à l'eau se sont pas réalisées
m non non non
même nom de famille mais la bannière est
bien différent 14 heures sans pause
annonce fera on travaille pas de
ce filtre qui est à la tête du parti
action laval qui a récupéré des
conseillers qui ont claqué la porte du
parti du maire demers en 2018 l'enjeu de
ce faire que les gens vont retomber en
amour avec la politique ils recommencent
à y croire parce que ce qu'on a enfin
depuis les dernières années mais
premièrement les gens sont surtaxés - la
première est déjà ne comprenait pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles mentent aux
journaux aux taxes alors pour vos pots
grand chose qui livrait les budgets la
gouvernance les michel poisson faisait
aussi partie des dissidents du mouvement
lavallois lui aussi critique la gestion
de l'administration actuelle devenue
trop bureaucratique koons a peut-être
volé mais nos services de proximité auto
rendez-vous plis taxes augmentées peau
ça c'est le sentiment déjà la montagne
sont à la base il a fondé son parti pour
briguer la mairie sa promesse par
l'aménagement d'un sentier linéaire de 8
km la pandémie nous rappeler que l'accès
à la nature est une donnée fondamentale
les lavallois nous le rappelle est que
les tours l'a conduit cause partout que
bien non suffisamment
ce roman l'environnement reste l'enjeu
du 21e siècle on souhaite la création
d'un grand parc sur la rivière des
mille-îles conseil on va faire une
demande pour que la vie soit d'autre
deux doigts de préhension si un terrain
de golf qui va être vendu que la ville
puisse pouvoir avoir le premier choix
puis de l'acheter au prix du marché
évidemment qu
on va financer entre 50 et 70% d'une
part
sur
les promesses environnementales prennent
de plus en plus de place dans la
campagne à laval et c'est justement
l'objectif du candidat indépendant
nicolas lemire à 25 ans il se présente
pour la deuxième fois à la mairie connu
pour son blog qui s'intitule pas le
maire de laval il a publié un manifeste
de 48 propositions pour la transition
écologique j'ai commencé par envoyer se
manifestera à tous les partis politiques
qui je leur ai demandé de s'approprier
les addictions dedans moi je veux que ça
se réalise moi je veux que sur les
bulletins de vote de lavallois il ya eu
il ya le plus d'options progressistes et
écologistes possible une façon
d'influencer les idées croit-il de
contrer le manque d'intérêt des citoyens
pour la politique municipale issigeac
audrey charbonneau radio-canada l'avant